talking about the true rife version 6.2. So true rife updated to 6.1 earlier this year and I was
very hesitant to use it because it had a lot of bugs in it. So anybody that started with us and
got a rife from us prior to the last week it got 6.0 and because 6.1 has had too many bugs now they've
upgraded to 6.2 as of last week and you can't download 6.0 or 6.1 any longer. So anybody that's
new that got a rife this week or last week there it will be version 6.2. Now I have on our member site
and on the rife resources page on the member's home page and on the frequency site have some
warnings. So you could go and download 6.2 and if you do it's going to wipe out your programs just so
you know so you're going to have to send your computer if you do do that you're going to have to
send your computer back to us because we have to put your programs in and it's a totally different
operation. Your programs that any programs that were created for you or that you created yourself
but anything that we created for you would be in a different folder. So for those who just got their
rife, I don't know if anybody's on here who just got a rife it is running 6.2 well you already know
actually created a video for people who are running 6.2 and it's on the member site in a couple
places and on the frequency course as well. So this video explains how you would get to your personal
program and it's just two extra steps it's no big deal if you never use the right before but if you're
used to version 5.0 or for people who have been with us a long time or you're used to version 6.0
which we upgraded everybody to in 2001 then it would be two extra steps you go oh well this is
dumb I have two extra steps but it's just they're hoping to get it changed in by version 6.4
there's some positive upgrades it was very very frustrating week last week because
multiple rifes that we got shipped to us had bad boards and we had to we were fighting with that
till we figured that out and version 6.2 was an upgrade and that was a big giant pain in the two
weeks too so we got it all figured out now Jake at true rif has been a wonderful help he's just been
you know really trying to get everything working correctly they just upgraded you know some things
on 6.2 for us so I'm very thankful for what they're doing I do think as especially I do think the 6.2
is it's is going to have more you know possible uses and the programs are the same understand so
the programs so don't take oh why should upgrade to 6.2 because the programs are going to be better
more powerful no the programs are all the same there's no new programs they're not better they're not
more powerful it's just what they're trying to get to do with the right in the future so they're going
through these program changes so my suggestion again is if you're running 6.0 continue to do so but
moving forward if your computer goes Kapooie and we need to get a new computer it's going to have to
be a 6 it's going to have to be a 6.2 or maybe 6.3 or 6.4 depending on when that happens maybe it'll
be a totally different version and it'll be in the Soviet viewpoint but um and then secondly moving
forward um we were trying to keep our costs down for our patients and if you wanted a new computer
we were able to sell those at a lower fee they didn't have they only had four eight ram I think
which was fine to run the rife good to say I run my rife at home on a Windows 7 computer so it's
not that you need a lot of RAM to run your rife program but moving forward we are going to use
true rife computers and they are much more stealthful it's just um especially with the new 6.2
software it runs better on a computer that has got a little bit more juice to it so that the cost
is going to be the same it's the cost of true rife but if you do get a new computer from true rife
you're still going to have to send it to us in order for us to put on your programs because
it's a little complicated on our part we have to create a new file and we have to put your programs
in that file in the document file to where to explain but um it's not something you could do we can't
just send you a flash drive um to do that anymore so that's not going to be impossible so in the 6.2
programs 6.2 program it's not going to be as easy to send you a flash drive now you could do it
if you're really super computer savvy um but for most people you're going to have to send your computer
back to us that means that you can watch that video it's on the master page no need for you to do it
but just for you to get a better idea what i'm talking about